this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know the cash app is the number
one app in finance but did you realize
that you can get the most powerful debit
card in the world with the cash apps
cash card just select a boost in your
cash app swipe the cash card and save
10% or more at Whole Foods Shake Shack
chipotle taco bell chick-fil-a and all
coffee shops around the country we'll
talk about this more later on in the
show
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market blue
apron with the holidays fast approaching
approaching meal prep is the last thing
you want on your plate so what if
cooking delicious wholesome meals was
easy it can be with blue apron you
choose chef's designed recipes and blue
apron delivers fresh seasonally inspired
ingredients cook incredible meals in as
little as twenty minutes check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals free at blue apron com / Congrats
that's blue apron com / congrats to get
your first three meals free blue apron a
better way to cook hey guys what's up it
is episode 98 of congratulations and
this is gonna be a [ __ ] doozy as as
the guy who got into that elevator once
with me said it's a doozy he said doozy
I don't remember there's some story I
kinda have remember where I gotta get
onto an elevator with me and said doozy
or something and that's it and that's by
the way the way this podcast is going to
be I'm gonna [ __ ] half I kind of know
what's going on but I also kind of don't
because let me tell you something man
I've [ __ ] moved I moved houses and
which means we're gonna get a whole new
studio and right now this is the last
time probably we're gonna be doing this
studio we're gonna be doing this podcast
in this studio it's gonna look the same
it's going to be remnants of the same
and
but it's gonna be a little bit different
because it's in gonna be in a different
room and that's how it goes
now listen because of that we don't have
the internet here so one fire and well
pretty much just one fire cuz I've been
get rid of isn't really the internet guy
but one fire his job has been reduced to
sitting okay it's been reduced to
sitting he's we have no internet we have
no furniture except for this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that we have in this there's no
furniture in my house except for this
studio and one fire we don't have the
internet and when I said to one fire
hey I don't have internet he said okay
and got here and then when we got here
he did the quintessential hey guess what
I thought you meant when you didn't have
internet you didn't have internet in
your new place now why the [ __ ] would I
tell him that I didn't have internet in
my new place when we were going to be
recording him our place now that's very
interesting to me however we're gonna
let it slide and so right now we don't
have internet and we don't even have a
chair for him so he went outside and
brought in a [ __ ] rocking chair so
he's sitting there like a goddamn
grandma and I'm doing my podcast in
episode 19 my babies and he's sitting
there like a goddamn grandma and it's
all good my babies it's free can't you
can sit in whatever the [ __ ] you want to
but he's rocking could you sit in a
rocking chair and not rock I don't think
I don't think that not not really
everyone feels them fills themselves
enough to sit when they sit in a rocking
chair to rock it back and forth that's
how you do it yeah so anyway big changes
coming to the log cabin big changes
coming to the [ __ ] actual life of me
and you know it's whatever we dohe not
only do we have not an internet internet
we have we don't have a cell service so
this is like a real log cabin in the
[ __ ] this is the real log cabin that
we're in not having [ __ ] cell service
not having what do you call it internet
so that's what's up anyway
I'm feeling okay today
dude I went to [ __ ] therapy talked
about a little bit about my anger issues
sometimes I don't really didn't really
think I had anger issues until recently
when in the past two three years started
blaming everybody else for everything
that is my fault
so it's all good let's skip over that
and not get to series too quickly but
yeah I [ __ ] didn't even really write
[ __ ] down for this episode I'm like this
is gonna be the let's just talk about
one thing do it I forget what I was
talking about this with but I was
talking about it with somebody was
talking about Instagram and this was it
one of my buddies somewhere was talking
about how he's done with Instagram
meeting girls off Instagram because they
just don't look like they do in person
and it's like all and it's a lie we were
talking about how it's a lie it's a
straight-up lie if you're a girl and you
look one way on Instagram I guess guys
do it too but like but probably not
because it's not makeup there's not that
guys don't really give a [ __ ] that much
about the angles unless that's their
thing they're models which every girl
thinks they're a model though on
Instagram so it doesn't really matter
but like these girls will post a picture
that is just not them straight up it's
like they might as well be in a [ __ ]
kabuki mask and then they and then they
and then they and then you I guess you
meet them and they look like somebody
else and that's crazy how that's like a
straight up [ __ ] Liz I you know it's
a straight up [ __ ] lie they're saying
I'm like oh there was a whole thing what
was it called black fishing or whatever
the the the model that was like a white
girl but she used bronze makeup and she
like tried to get the full lips and a
big booty that's the you know the
quote-unquote you know I guess ethnic
look or whatever and then people who
were like you know
women who were like black or you know
latina were like hey this is our look
you're trying to [ __ ] you know up
you're appropriating our look and [ __ ]
like that and and then the girl is like
this is just I got a tan what do you
want me to [ __ ] do and I got blood
implants I can't take them out you know
anyway my point is is if you're a girl
and you are posting pictures where you
don't look like you and you know what
those goddamn pictures are then that's
like saying that's like meeting a guy
and saying I own a casino and you don't
own a casino and when you're found out
and when someone says you're dating a
guy and you're like yeah what do you do
oh you know I [ __ ] own a casino it's
all good I got a lot of money cuz this
casinos community I make a lot of money
off the casino and then and then you
find out the the ladies like oh you
don't but you don't own a casino and why
do you work at a [ __ ] Bank of America
as a teller instead of going to the
casino everyday and then as a guy you
say well I don't know what you're
talking about
I own a goddamn casino and sticking with
that
that's your online presence as a man
telling someone you own a goddamn casino
and sticking with it even though you
know and they know you don't own a
goddamn casino that's what it is
that's what it's like ladies when you
post a picture where you look like a
[ __ ] mannequin and then you show up
and you look like a troglodyte chu doin
dude you're lying
so I own a casino and I make millions
and millions and millions and millions
and billions of dollars off of the
casino and morongo dude my opener has a
Miami Dolphins hat that he wears and it
has an M and it looks like it's a
[ __ ] morongo hat and every time he
sees it I say all cool [ __ ] morongo
had you done dude I'm gonna be in
can Fresno and Bakersfield for some
reason this weekend and I'm gonna do
shows for some way or some reason and
it's gonna be [ __ ] probably awful to
be there because it's there but you know
what
come on outfit fellas and babe and I'll
come on out babies so I'm gonna drive up
to Fresno I'm gonna [ __ ] stay there
the night then I'm gonna go down to
Bakersfield then I'm gonna leave
Bakersfield and come back home and the
next time we do this podcast it's gonna
be in the new studio and it's gonna be
on and the guy who's building my new
podcast room his name for real in real
life really is one he's one hire though
cuz I'm gonna hire him so yeah I did
shows at The Comedy Store that shows
that the [ __ ] life is good man life
is honestly all you know what I [ __ ]
realized this week that I hate that I
realized it too because people say this
but attitude is everything man it really
is if you're in a bad mood you look dead
if you're in a good mood you're livin
babies
I got shoulder pain check back pain
check but if I'm constantly thinking
about it I'm dead and I look I look less
attractive too if I'm thinking about my
shoulder pain I'm thinking about my back
pain and walking around and I'm like I
look less attractive man the ladies
aren't batting their ashes lashes to
that but if I'm like [ __ ] dis shoulder
pain [ __ ] this back pain um coming up
and I'm walking around and I'm feeling
good the ladies are batting their lashes
that's what's happening man I'm noticing
Jessica Rabbit everywhere yeah dude
all that because III I you know what I
did that week this week I figured that
out I'm smart I'm [ __ ] smart as [ __ ]
do it cuz I figured it out
but I also realized this week that I'm
one traumatic thing happening to just my
brain breaking and being a crazy person
like straight up like if somebody
stabbed me like it would be so traumatic
and I lived it'd be so traumatic I would
just change I would just be done I'd
just be like a mumbler or if someone
like really big and hulking just put me
in a corner and just groped my [ __ ] and
like went so far down that even that
about that that he went under it and
then part of his finger went in my
[ __ ] I would be done done right then
done right then if a Hulk came in
cornered me in the back of a comedy club
while that while everyone was gone and
just went committee and [ __ ] just
straight up you know palm to my [ __ ]
under my undercarriage and my [ __ ]
taint to where his finger went under it
and and went and not even in my anus but
touched my anus a little bit done that's
it guess what I am after that from then
on I'm a mumbler I'm just a guy that's
gonna be what you're talking about with
the talking find another government it's
gonna puff gonna be doing this [ __ ]
that's it my brain broke as soon as his
[ __ ] finger hit my anus my brain goes
and that's it and that's it and then I'm
a mumbler that's it dude I can't handle
any more and I haven't even handled that
much I've got a good life but that's it
dude I'm one traumatic thing somebody
stabs my midsection and I make it
through it that's it if a Hulk corners
me and grabs my [ __ ] balls and anus
that's it you ever had your [ __ ] anus
grabbed that's how far away I am from my
brain breaking one anus grab I'm one
anus grab I'm one anus grab away from my
brain breaking and there's your [ __ ]
quote I'm a [ __ ]
if I ever run for mayor that's what I'm
my platform is remember we are all one
anus grab away from our brain breaking I
own a casino
I own a casino I make money from a
casino
excuse me mr. D'Elia mayor we know that
you don't have a casino at all I don't
know what you're talking about
I have a casino I own one I make money
from it I get percentages please can we
get a reporter to ask me a question now
that looks somewhat like her Instagram
page I mean dude you know [ __ ] you know
what this podcast is truly devolve into
now that we don't have internet and I've
on get rid of and I and I'm on higher as
sitting here in this small room with me
is just like literally they feel like
doctors and I'm a [ __ ] crazy person
losing my mind they're not even doing
anything ones in a rocking chair for
[ __ ] sake and I'm just sitting here
talking to nobody there's nobody in here
right now when I'm doing this literally
nobody is in here and I'm i you know i
hope this winds up on the internet but
who the [ __ ] knows maybe maybe this is
all in my head this is like Fight Club
what's that movie song that goes stop
the pixies song from there isn't that
doesn't it start with that somebody's
saying stop in my mind where is my mind
I'm on fire and one higher stop I wish
we had internet dude I would [ __ ]
stop the worst representation of it of
all time I'll drink coffee on you
[ __ ] man so that's
that's it man this reminds me of the
time I was in Australia and I had to do
the podcast anyway I'll [ __ ] never
stop doing this podcast I will stop
though
I honestly swear to God I will stop if
you stop listening if the second we
start going down I'm done that's it so
tell the babies tell recruit babies dude
no no no this Kevin Hart thing is
[ __ ] crazy I wonder who's gonna end
up hosting the Oscars
I think they need they need a you know
what they need for real
I think they if they get somebody that's
too progressive they're gonna piss off
everyone else that was the other half
like if you get Hannon and that Gatsby
or whatever if you get handed the Great
Gatsby then you're gonna you're gonna
piss off everyone you're gonna piss off
everyone else and they don't want to do
that either I think they need to get a
robot they need to get a [ __ ] robot
they need to get a [ __ ] like
feminine-looking male robot to just come
out and be like hello it's the 2018
Oscar Awards this 2019 I guess it'd be
19 right 2018 2019 Oscar Awards everyone
here his family and then it bleeds out
of its [ __ ] dick and it's like ha ha ha
well that's natural hello nominated for
Best Picture
that nominations for Best Picture this
is Green Book whoops
more blood coming down the leg that's
natural Best Picture the [ __ ] one
with Steve Carell and the boys whatever
that one was that is for sure boring
whoops I'm standing in blood that's not
trol and then it cuts to Jonah Hill just
like hello nominations for best actor
ass Meryl Streep of course was she even
in a movie this year it doesn't matter
drip whoops that's natural I just
slipped in my blood then it cuts to
[ __ ] the guy from Black Panther just
in a coat that's too long for him just
like welcome the blacks and Asians and
whites whoops that isla and then the the
him/her robot falls and slips and
there's like [ __ ] period blood all
over is like the robot face and then the
people who keep coming up accepting
their awards they like that she hands
that she hands the award to the person
and there's blood all over the award and
then but everyone who wins like speaking
afterwards in the [ __ ] the the post
talk where they like talk about who else
they want to thank and she had backstage
there's like blood all over their [ __ ]
dresses and face and then and then one
guy is like I don't know what's up with
all this [ __ ] why they had to have
period blood all over and then and then
that person gets slammed so hard the
next day and loses his [ __ ] career
and it's like Will Ferrell said the
thing and then we looked up old tweets
also that's natural uh
and then just [ __ ] like and then it
but the the male robot would have weird
ass like pancake tits like not even like
good ones but like bad ones did just
just just to [ __ ] like draw out the
trolls on the internet that'll be like
look at her [ __ ] gross tits and then
that personal adult is their job it's
natural to have flat boobs
after I I fed my robot daughters and
sons with this so now they're flat do
not make fun of motherhood it's natural
and then and then they gave a too long
speech and then the robot comes up and
just [ __ ] manhandles this [ __ ] out of
them
just like rip some off stage like that's
the only thing that malfunctions and
just [ __ ] and there's blood all over
them falling all over the place but
they're trying to [ __ ] bring him
backstage and they fall down a little
bit and [ __ ] Tim Timothy shell
Duvalier is all [ __ ] blood up and
who's trying to drag him off with the
intimidate images of valhalla da just
has [ __ ] hey what's up with these
[ __ ] with the names man Timothy
Chevalier with the [ __ ] his name Jim
Chalam a [ __ ] out of here Timothy
sha'lame Shalem a you know is there a
[ __ ] Moorcock name than sha'lame is
he's American - right
or is he British how could you not be
British with the last name sha'lame and
I am well obviously it's from [ __ ]
but it like was he born in Pittsburgh
though you know people are from where
they're from but where they're from
where they're from that's annoying as
[ __ ] - when people are like yeah I'm
from you know New Jersey but I'm Italian
it's like yeah okay you're American you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] um but what also
what was the [ __ ] I was I was
listening to this thing on what the [ __ ]
was it some podcast some [ __ ] ass
podcast listen is actually good
oh the TED radio hour dude the guy who
does the [ __ ] Ted radio hour this is
another thing - I would play if I had it
but I don't have it
but the but the guy they were talking
about fortune cookies this guy's voice
is the guy they always bring it to the
most dramatic - [ __ ] [ __ ] - like this
lady was talking about how Chinese food
American Chinese food is way different
than Chinese Chinese food like there's
no fortune cookies if you give a fortune
cookie to somebody in Beijing they're
like why the [ __ ] is there paper in this
fortune cookie that's an American thing
at General Tso's chicken is an American
thing because if you bring up general
Chow his name in China they're like oh
yeah the [ __ ] famous general that
killed 20 million people but here we
know him is chicken so they are talking
about that and then they always bring
this [ __ ] [ __ ] sometimes they really
try to fit it in they're like like what
does he say at the end of this it's
really funny actually here in the United
States if you're Chinese too often to be
fruit wait so when you go to a Chinese
restaurant there's kind of a wink and
somebody will give you fruit if I go
it's like we cannot it's just understood
it's like a like a whole different
parallel we don't know so they'll do
this [ __ ] and then at the end they'll
say the guy will say so they're gonna
always try to bring around to something
grand or point and it often isn't a
grand point they're just like trying
he'll be like so maybe it's not
important that Chinese food is different
whatever continent you're on maybe it's
the fact that life hands like what but
you can get hypnotized and be like oh oh
yeah no you can get hypnotized into the
guys the guy's voice is so like so let
me get this straight if you're in baking
and you give Chinese you give a fortune
cookie
to somebody in Beijing they'll look you
weird and she'll be like yeah I've done
it I did it for 20 years there's always
somebody who's like did some study for
way too long that's the most boring a
study so we're talking to a woman that
went to Beijing and
and handed out fortune cookies for 25
years all in the name of science and now
let me ask you Linda how how many how
many times did a Chinese person from
China actually eat the fortune cookie
and understand that it was what
Americans thought or Chinese did um none
so let me ask you a question then do we
all die I guess yeah and then you're
you're supposed to be like this when you
listen to it Oh somebody's got us that's
changing it's the weather they sound so
smug it's not bad it's it's good a lot
of it is really good but we're gonna
take you back to a time where the
dinosaurs were on the earth nope
with a dinosaurs or were they just
versions of us I don't want to be on
that and I want to just be like they
were [ __ ] dinosaurs are you angry or
is it simply us that are angry what I'm
you you're me wrong sort of connected he
and he ends their everything with a
[ __ ] question - even if it's not
maybe it's the fact that we're all
connected see this way if he's wrong he
could be like being wrong it's about
being right the wrong way yeah okay man
[ __ ] off welcome to Ted Radio Hour where
it's not TED talk but it's another thing
it's called Ted Radio Hour this way we
can have two different podcasts called
TED talk and Ted Radio Hour and we can
make more money we could have the same
ads in both podcasts you'll stop both of
them and we'll just make more money
maybe stop the fact that we're making
money that we're growing is it the
weather hymns you guys understand this
66% if you don't understand it you will
sixty sixty six percent of men lose
their hair by age 35 now I'm 38 have I
noticed it sitting yes is my hairline
going back and back check do I look more
like Christopher Lloyd yes every day
goes by do I look more like I'm gonna
say multi yes every day do I look more
and more like I'm gonna talk about
gigawatts yes the thing is when you
start to notice hair loss it's too late
and you can't go back in time
you aren't Christopher Lloyd in Back to
the Future so it's easier to keep the
hair you have is what I'm trying to say
then to replace the hair you've lost is
that hair line slowly starting to move
backwards any bald spots yes yet yeah
probably if you're over 35 I asked you
do you want a bald spot to pop up or do
you want to do something about it first
yeah you want to do something about
first do you want to hairline to recede
or do you want to do something about it
first come on guys
you can turn to medicine and science it
works
for hims calm a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for men
hims connects you with real doctors and
medical degrade solutions to treat hair
loss it's not snake oil pills you know
gas station counter supplements they're
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair no waiting room no
awkward person in person doctor visits
products are shipped directly to your
door order now my listeners get a trial
month of hymns for just $5 today right
now while supplies last
see website for full details this would
cost hundreds if you went to the doctor
or a pharmacy go to for hemes dot-com
slash Congrats
that's fo r hims com / congrats for hims
for hims com / congrats me Indies
well I wear I'm wearing them right now I
got my funky little uh kind of zebra
blue zebra pin print on
they're one of my favorites and this is
the year that you can finally tackle
your holiday shopping early which I
never do but guess what you can get
everything you need for your loved ones
at me undies you really can me undies
uses the coveted micro modal fabric
which is three times softer than cotton
if you have never felt this fabric
you're missing out get ready to
experience pure bliss and underwear form
I'm serious man when I put these on I
thought I was swimming they're awesome
you can also get a style that is
perfectly suited for you men and women
can each choose from four different cuts
all of which are available from classic
colors too adventurous prints
speaking of princess holiday season me
undies will be releasing a new print
every Tuesday that means you'll have no
excuse not to celebrate the holidays
right down to your very core but why
stop at me undies this year me undies is
launching their holiday prints and
lounge pants and onesies as well both
are made from the same micro metal
fabric as their undies seriously how can
you not get you and your loved ones a
matching holiday themes themed onesie
this year is a no-brainer get 50% 15%
off a pair of the most comfortable on
undies you will ever put on to get your
50% off your first pair pair free
shipping and a 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me on these dot-com
slash Congrats that's me undies dot-com
slash Congrats zebra it has been
reported that Americans are overpaying
on car insurance by over 21 billion
dollars billion dollars but for
searching but searching for a better
deal can take hours and typically result
in a barrage of unwanted spam calls
until now thanks to zebra comm the zebra
comm is the nation's leading car
insurance comparison to the site because
it's the only place you can compare
hundreds of policies from all the top
carriers and choose the best for you
plus they will never sell your
information to the spammers so you won't
get all those unwanted calls or emails
just answer a few questions on a simple
fast form and they find you the best
rates and coverage in your state
it's like kayak for auto insurance it's
quick and it's easy this is definitely
one of those things that should have
existed before and it's a great service
this is how buying car insurance should
be are you comparing and
surance before you buy or are you not
comparing insurance before you buy
chewed doing go today and start saving
the zebra at the zebra dot-com /
Congrats that's the zebra dot-com /
Congrats spelled th e ze b ra comm /
Congrats now okay what were you having
Nuria okay that's a fart noise for you
and I do cuz I'm disrespectful yeah man
I watched this [ __ ] thing last night
and I don't know I was told to watch the
[ __ ] Darren brown by the way you know
this guy's like The Mentalist or
whatever Darren is the most British
[ __ ] [ __ ] name it name it and his
name is Darren but Darren you know and
every time you google Darren brown it
says did you mean Darren brown and I
want to be like no Google I meant Darren
brown and he should change his name but
I watched the [ __ ] thing now he's
like this Mentalist that'll be like it's
so I don't he did I talked about it a
long time ago it was the push it was
called push on Netflix and he gets a guy
to [ __ ] kill somebody which is like
ridiculous but he like basically just
plays on there he selects the right
people first of all he weeds out the non
bitch-made betas and then he picks up
the bitch-made betas and then he's like
I'm going to merely suggest a bunch of
little things to this man and eventually
he's going to end up you know impairing
himself on a sword just to find out if
it's even possible like so fought you
know so this one is called the SS and I
was told to watch it and because it was
amazing and I watched it and it's
basically about a guy who's you know
it's Darren brown here he comes and he's
like the guy who killed Robert Kennedy
was it was said he said
Sirhan Sirhan was does his name and he
was said he said that he was hypnotized
to kill somebody now
the whole thing about him does a
hypnotized Asian is that you can't you
supposedly not be able to hypnotize
somebody into doing something that they
wouldn't normally do
right so you can hypnotize someone and
be like hey go [ __ ] take a [ __ ] in the
bathroom right now and you be like okay
gotta go take a [ __ ] and you go take a
[ __ ] in the bathroom but maybe you
wouldn't believe minute eyes and be like
hey go take a [ __ ] in the middle of
Starbucks because you wouldn't
necessarily normally do that now if your
[ __ ] made beta which a lot of the guys
that Darren brown weeds out these guys
apparently Darren brown is saying you
could make somebody possibly go take a
[ __ ] in the middle of Starbucks but also
more importantly you can make hypnotize
somebody to go kill somebody because
that's what sirhan sirhan says has no
memory of it and he still to this day
says he was hypnotized or whatever the
[ __ ] right so he made this thing to see
if it would he if it was even possible
and so he goes to he gets this guy and
he gets this guy to do a bunch of [ __ ]
that he wouldn't normally do like not
feel cold if he's in a ice and ice
bucket and then he snaps his fingers and
the guy's like huh it's freezing and
he's like and I made you feel like it's
not cold and he's like well how'd you do
that oh my god and he's just [ __ ] this
empty [ __ ] ass that will do anything
anyone else says right cuz there's
levels of people like imagine imagine
here's the thing imagine me being
hypnotized that's not gonna work cuz you
know I'm gonna be like the [ __ ] he
talkin about
imagine Joe Rogan being hypnotized it's
not gonna work right but if you imagine
a bitch-ass [ __ ]
that's like wait where do I go like that
kind of guy he gets [ __ ] for sure
hypnotized but Darren Brown does [ __ ]
like hey let me let me see your hand let
me shake your hand and then he'll touch
his for it'll be like no sleep now what
he did was and the guy will just [ __ ]
fall down and fall asleep and I'm like
that's [ __ ] horseshit right I'll look
at my girl I'll be like that's horseshit
right and she's like yeah that's
horseshit but then I'm like watching the
[ __ ] thing and it seems real like
these people don't seem like actors so
he falls and falls asleep and the guys
out cold and
just sleeping cuz he touched his head
and Darren Brown's like so what I did
was we took a normal activity where he
shook my hand and then I interrupted
that and when you interrupt something in
a normal activity it checks the body up
and then when I touch the their head it
interrupts it even more and then what
happens is I'm so confident that they
fall asleep and which is like okay okay
so okay so uh I don't know anybody in my
life that that would happen to but okay
alright so now he spends the whole show
trying to hypnotize this guy uh to kill
somebody so he shows him the polka dot
these polka dot wallpaper shits and he's
like yeah if you ever see this you're
gonna [ __ ] go into a trance and then
kill someone so he has a go to a [ __ ]
auditorium where a guy speaking Stephen
Fry by the way who I've worked with it's
just a funny [ __ ] comedian from
Britain and he's talking and this lady
in the polkadot dress comes and sits in
front of the [ __ ] [ __ ] as beta and
the guy goes like must kill you know and
then just [ __ ] pulls a gun out and
that that he was given to by Darren
brown and for some reason this guy was
like hey I'll hold the gun for you and
just didn't understand what's going on
and then literally lapsed in memory and
just shot Stephen Fry with blanks
obviously and then Stephen friend
Stephen Fry fell on the ground and then
later on when the kid when the [ __ ] has
beta snaps out of it Darren Brown's like
so what happened he's like I just
watched Stephen Fry do a lecture
he's like okay anything else happened
and he was like no now and Darren brown
I was like what if I told you that you
can't you shot stir fry and the guy's
like Oh what what and he's like you shot
him Stephen Fry was like you shot me and
he's like well and they show him video
of it and he's like that's not me I did
that I it's just so like hey man who are
you man he
no memory of it so I guess my question
for the babies is do you believe in that
or not have you ever been hypnotized cuz
I wouldn't even [ __ ] say okay
hypnotize me cuz I'd be like yo no cuz
it's not gonna work so you have to be
suggestible is that the word I don't
know but like I wanted him to be like
hey here's the thing that would I would
here's the thing that would sell me on
hypnotize him franchising someone will
be worth it would be would be true like
I even killing someone I don't believe
that I believe okay maybe secretly he
wanted to do it to get away with it and
then blame it on hypnotizing I believe
you hypnotizing works if you hypnotize
someone to suck a guy's dick and they're
not gay that's I believe then then I'll
believe it works so Darren brown your
next special I want you to be like I am
getting a roomful of hardcore straight
homophobic men and what we're doing is
we are going to try and get them to suck
each other off and then they're like now
when you see polka dots
remember I want you to get horny for
another man and I want you to I want you
to become gay and I want you to suck
that guy's dick and then when they see
the polka dot thing they're gonna the
guy oh go like must suck and then gets
on his [ __ ] knees and then just start
but they have to make sure the other guy
also or no you know what it should be a
gay guy it should be a gay guy that's
like yeah that's right yeah do it then I
would believe it suck him off to
completion when you see polka dots
you're going to want to suck a guy off
to complete
here you go and then a guy walks in with
a polka dot dress and he's just like
must sock off gets on his knees and then
afterwards are like so just come all
over his face
what happened and he's like I don't know
what happened did I eat a glazed
doughnut no and other guys there with
just no pants on and he's just all spent
and he's just like what did what just
what does happen he's like I don't know
I was just in a room full of guys who
were just chilling no what if I told you
you sucked a guy off well I had no way
I'm not gay
[ __ ] that well here's video and it's
just a [ __ ] [ __ ] video just gotta
floss oh and everybody's like now and
for the face and you hear his voice all
right so it's off Volf in just some
[ __ ] fat guy in a polkadot dress just
fall off and the guys like yeah okay
cool yeah yeah
kind of in my mouth and he's like well I
didn't do that
congratulations you're gay no no yeah
I've watched gay with turned round and
on that nothing on it don't there here's
a tower
man on it here's this for him to eat the
rest then on it no man on there how
about the porns where they do that do it
it's like you know what sex is degrading
enough if you're a guy who gets off on
being degrading you know during sex it's
degrading enough do you know why you're
mounting someone so you don't need to go
the whole nine and come on someone's
face and then give them a spoon for the
rest of it you ever see that porn I
guess I have because I'm a sexual
deviant but I'm not but they'll be like
here I saw one where a guy [ __ ]
spurred it into a [ __ ] glass and it
was like drink it like what hey he got
probs what if I told you you had a guy
come into a Gus and then you drank it
well I didn't do it oh no his video of
it Oh floss floss nope nope Brown maybe
it's not about being gay maybe it's
about being hypnotized [ __ ] idiot
maybe we're all gay maybe it's a sliding
scale maybe it's like what Kinsey said
it's on a scale from one to six maybe
most of us fall somewhere between and
it's very rare that we're a six
heterosexual or a one homosexual
maybe we're all threes all right
blue apron with the holiday fast
approach approaching meal prep is the
last thing you want on your plate and
that's just true look guys I speak the
truth and that's just true
I eat blue apron all the time all the
time I love it I have yet to eat a bad
meal from blue apron I cook I clean it's
a cinch and I'm lazy and I eat the
chicken I eat the pork I eat the fish I
eat the lettuce I eat all of it and it's
great they make it simple dude and it's
real food blue apron really gives me a
better way to cook chef designed recipes
that use fresh seasonally inspired
ingredients meals worth sharing on
social media because they're
picture-perfect and as little as 20
minutes time-saving tips and technique
it's very is very easy and it's really
good it's the best of both worlds it
takes to chew out a meal prep I never
have to worry about last-minute trips or
forgotten ingredients tape supply
everything featured upcoming meals
include seared steaks we
loaded mashed potatoes and panko crusted
chicken and maple dipping sauce
you ever have panko crusted chicken
forget it
it's amazing maple and maple anything is
good but maple dipping sauce
yum-yum so check out this week's menu
and get your first three Mills free at
blue apron calm / Congrats that's blue
apron calm / congrats to get your first
three meals free blue apron a better way
to cook you guys heard of this tipsy
elves listen I got this onesie from
tipsy elves and it's great I didn't
expect for it to be so chilling and it's
chilling dude I just moved into a new
house I got boxes upon boxes all over
the place stressful but I put on this
onesie and I'm in chill mode it's
awesome dude you won't find more
hilariously awesome designs anywhere
else now I picked the cool you know
reindeer on it with the hood and all
that so be sure to order from tipsy
elves in time for your ugly Christmas
sweater party
they got sweaters they got everything
and right now my listeners get 20% off
tipsy elves calm when you use my code
Congrats that checkout that's 20% off
anything you order on this site go to
tipsy elves calm and enter my code
Congrats at checkout to get your 20% off
site-wide discount cool cash app you
already know the cash app is the number
one I up in finance but did you realize
that you can get the most powerful debit
card in the world with cash apps cash
card the cash card comes with boosts a
feature you can get anywhere else
because cash app invented it that you
can't get anywhere else sorry because
cash app invented it just select a boost
in your cash app swipe the cash card and
save 10% or more at Whole Foods the
Shake Shack chipotle taco bell
chick-fil-a and all coffee shops around
the country the coffee shop boost takes
$1 off at any coffee shop including
Dunkin Dunkin and Starbucks drink 100
cups a year save $100 is that simp
become a part of the greatest reward
program ever and download the ketchup
now it's the number one
for a reason and the cash card is the
only debit card with boosts and of
course when you download the cash up
into the referral code congrats you'll
receive five dollars in the cash up
we'll send five dollars to the times
little Defense Fund visit the App Store
or Google Play market and download the
cash app you don't mean only yeah I do
but I'll do it later
this [ __ ] guy dude one fire man we
don't have the internet so it's hard for
us to [ __ ] do this [ __ ] I'm doing the
ads all in the get in the wrong place
but it is what it is hey what you want
to know something that's so annoying
when your straw breaks and you got to
suck it up like all right it's like and
it's [ __ ] shooting on your shirt and
all that [ __ ] it's annoying I have a
hard life uh I'm a double keep doubling
it to a kill me uh what else happened
this week though yeah you do even know
guys I like how UMP Slyke what about
this individual one thing I love how it
Trump's like totally cleared wasn't me
and then they're like you're individual
one and he's like nah someone else how
does he even get away with that actually
dude he's got his thirty percent that
just will believe him Trump could come
out and be like hey I'm a frog I know
people will be like yeah he probably is
actually if you think about it this way
he's always hopping around different
areas one days talking in Phoenix and
another days in Washington it's big leap
but if you use any animal would be a
frog
yeah I don't know I'm not very political
I don't know much about it what I do
know is nothing that's what I do I don't
know what's that [ __ ] Mark Twain
quote where he's like I was so smart
when I was 16 but I [ __ ] don't know
dude I you know I don't give a [ __ ]
this whole thing's burning down and
you're with me oh that's what I should
talk about the knavish Patel is that his
name
the guy who are certain island life is
him his Nami tell who is who told a joke
on stage about how at a college and they
unplugged his microphone and how they
were like he was like doing a joke
stand-up that was like he said something
about being gay is obviously a choice
because there are black gay guys I'm
paraphrasing but he said why would you
choose to have two things that people
could you know be hateful against you
about right the crowd didn't respond I
didn't like it and then I guess a few
minutes later they came up on stage and
pulled his microphone and we're like hey
we're deciding to go a different way
with the rest of the show you've been
relieved and so you know it's it's
obviously that the the colleges choice
to do that and I get it and free speech
doesn't mean that they can't [ __ ]
take unplug his microphone because it's
a college and they can do it if the [ __ ]
they want and if they don't want to hire
somebody that does that then they can
fire them on the spot I get it I'm not
like they [ __ ] solid to them or
whatever that's what American no it's
very American to do that if you want to
however it is not it does not benefit
you to not hear what people have to say
for instance
one time I told a joke on stage where I
said something about how I'm I just
gonna sound [ __ ] but I said something
about how I'm gross or something I'm not
a I'm not if something like I'm
unattractive or something like that and
a a girl in the audience goes oh shut up
stop no you're not or something and I
couldn't tell the rest of the joke which
was a joke on the joke where I was going
to explain why I wasn't gross or why I
was more attractive or some [ __ ]
stupid joke I was doing I can't remember
but because she did that she didn't
listen to the rest of the jokes is you
didn't understand what I was trying to
[ __ ] say she just heard the first
part of it that's obviously not a
problem because who cares it's about
nothing but this guy possibly the rest
of the joke could have been something
else that would have been illuminating
for this college or you just my point is
listen to the whole thing and then
decide you silencing somebody or
deciding somebody can't speak is only
hurting you because then you don't you
don't get to hear the whole thing and
then make a decision I mean it's not
[ __ ] easy it's that basic if you
don't get to hear the whole thing you
have to let people you hate talk because
if you don't do that then you won't know
what the [ __ ] they think you won't know
how to argue against it I mean there's
so much wrong with it if we say
hey white supremacists no don't say this
don't say that you can't do this you
can't do that then they're going to get
more mad and mobilize even more by the
way oh they're out to silence us let
them [ __ ] exhaust themselves we'll
learn more about it and decide maybe how
the [ __ ] do these guys get this way and
then maybe we'll be able to [ __ ] you
know diminish it as much as we can
because that's what you know should be
done I'm doing a very bad job of
explaining this but my point is you have
to let everybody talk free speech is
free speech because I think that maybe
the young generation doesn't believe in
free speech and even though that's what
America we fought so hard to get free
speech I mean it's been so many so many
so many so many so many so many years to
get to this point I mean now we're here
we're gonna [ __ ] it up a big time we
haven't even had it for that long you
know you got to be able to say what you
want you got to be able to joke how you
want you got to be able to say what you
want I mean for it to be a crime to say
something that's where we're headed you
know I don't know if we will get there
but if the youth is that way then next
thing you know the adults will be that
way because they grow mmm I know it's
all cyclical I guess but
it's just a weird thing to think about I
don't know when I go and I play these
colleges I get [ __ ] sometimes when if
they groan which is you know if you go
in with a different attitude - I don't
know - I'm like a little bit of a more
aggressive louder comic I feel like that
happens less to people like that because
you know we seem confident you know I
don't know anything about I don't know
anything about animation beetles act I
mean I'm sure he's hilarious the joke
seemed funny to me but I just feel like
they don't I'm waiting for the college's
to do that [ __ ] I'm waiting for them to
do that I'm waiting for them to be
offended can't wait because also it's
not all of them that think that like
there are definitely our people in the
colleges that are like oh no he should
be able to say what he wanted [ __ ] that
why did you end the show but the problem
is a shame because then those people can
be shamed would be like oh yeah but
that's the wrong way to think and like
yeah and then you ruin the [ __ ] guy's
career you're on the guy's [ __ ]
social life because they think a certain
way it's just man I don't know this
isn't very funny but this is how it is I
guess
because what was that thing in like
Spain where a comedian said something
political and then wound up in prison
wasn't in Spain camera can look it up
he's one of the Internet
but uh yeah it was like jailed or
something because of what he said
politically and that's the next few
steps if we don't [ __ ] stop bitching
and moaning about what people are saying
whatever do it I'm able to have this
podcast I could say whatever I want
right now so I guess I'm happy and I'm
Maria I'm already 38 so you know my life
is in full swing but dude if I have a
kid and he's gonna be like we can't draw
pictures of Jesus or whatever the [ __ ]
you know it's against the law
imagine hey what are you here for oh I
[ __ ] I raped and killed people what
are you in here for well I drew a
picture of Jesus holding a penis
whatever you know I don't [ __ ] know
anymore I'm just excited to get the
[ __ ] new studio going dude did you
get your wouldn't make wouldn't make a
dent shirts they shift them out finally
so if you didn't get them now you'll get
them soon I don't have mine of course
but Brendan Schaub and my dad have
theirs so I don't know how the [ __ ] that
happened but I created the goddamn
shirts don't have them all good one fire
but cool um at least I'm [ __ ]
dripping with sauce in this undefeated
get right now [ __ ] bowl of pasta ask
[ __ ] I'm also gonna be guest of
the year on fighter in the kid I don't
give a [ __ ]
I let Theo have it last time I let him
have it and I'm gonna get that belt and
I'm gonna melt it down to some [ __ ]
dangly earrings and I'm gonna wear them
dude like I'm mr. t on both sides I
don't give a [ __ ]
well we can't do craigslist ads either
we wanted to do that too do not contact
me with unsolicited [ __ ] calls or
whatever
hey saw you at Ralph's wanted to suck
you off let me know hit me up do not
contact knew that's still unsolicited
[ __ ] things
[ __ ] it I don't know what if I had a
radio job I'd be fired so hard they
wouldn't even be the offensive she had
to be like dude you're not you don't
care man
should I be done I can't take word
Twitter questions
dude this episode you know I'm coming to
[ __ ] where else was that I'm coming
to [ __ ] Austin in san antonio
Louisville Indianapolis st. Louis
Boulder Colorado Springs Salt Lake City
Madison Milwaukee Chicago Seattle
Hamilton Windsor Kalamazoo Anaheim San
Ynez Valley Center Albany Hanover
Huntington if you're city just [ __ ]
get tickets Cleveland Columbus
Cincinnati you know
Albuquerque for some reason Santa Fe for
some reason Phoenix Tucson Greensboro
for some reason Charlotte Durham Newport
News for some reason Oakland and Las
Vegas that's where we're going babies
and so check out this week's menu and
get your first three meals free up
brulee from home / congrats blue a 4 in
a better way to cook and I'll tell you
what to one of these episodes I'm just
gonna [ __ ] do ads all episode I'm
gonna take it it's gonna be the a depe
sowed and it's just because some guy
said well a lot of ads dude you I'm
gonna do all you know what I'm gonna do
all ads one episode and you think I'm
[ __ ] joking I am and it's gonna be
and I'm gonna get rich off that
[ __ ] I'm gonna do so many ads
it's gonna be [ __ ] 20 ads and I'm
just and it's gonna be 45 minutes and
then when I'm getting tired I go I take
a sip of coffee and I go no bits and you
listen to the whole [ __ ] thing and I
get
rich bro Brinks Dunbar Loomis back get
the [ __ ] up babies
for [ __ ] sake dude I mean I can't
believe we've done 98 episodes and we
got a special one to coming up for the
100th episode we got something special
coming for you [ __ ] you get to
learn a little bit more about me and you
get to learn a little bit more about
what's going on in my life I guess I
don't know but it is the hundredth
episode and coming up and we're excited
we'll have the new studio soon that's it
I guess that's it you guys this one was
the chill mode app man the chill mode
episode chill mode episode is that you
Mona pelant
so thank you for listening download the
Chris D'Elia app weren't able to do it
today but we will next time
and there's oh we have a new design
coming up in the merch it's got it's the
best I think it's the best one yet merch
team is killing it follow the leader
tour tickets Chris D'Elia calm and
that's it I'm gonna go but you guys are
great thanks for bearing with me on this
non-internet the the show with no
internet thanks for being with me
next time we'll be in the new studio and
we'll be [ __ ] killing it backing up
back back up the speed just [ __ ] you
know talking and googling and killing it
thanks guys
[Music]